il y as foule sur les rives du tigre
pour tenter de se rafraîchir avec des
températures dépassant parfois les 55
degrés la chaleur est difficilement
supportable pour les habitants de la
capitale irakienne
déjà éprouvée par la pandémie de
coronavirus mais le plus difficile pour
les bagdadiens c'est le manque
d'électricité
[Musique]
la température affecte l'état
psychologique pour nous les citoyens
ordinaires
on peut pas supporter ces températures
élevées si le gouvernement met de
l'électricité à disposition nous nous
sentirons soulagé et travailleront dans
de bonnes conditions
mais là nous ne pouvons pas vivre
correctement et nous nous demandons
comment faire pour que le gouvernement
rend l'électricité est disponible nous
rend à l'aise pour arriver à travailler
correctement avec l'électricité
disponible
nous sommes tous dehors
nous sommes tous en sueur si
l'électricité et est disponible nous
resterions à la maison en profitant de
la fraîcheur mais c'est un rêve
l'électricité est le pilier de la vie
l'électricité est essentiel au travail
tout comme les hôpitaux
la vie est brisée son aile après des
années de négligence le réseau public
irakien n'est pas capable de fournir
plus de quelques heures d'électricité
par jour
obligeant les irakiens se débrouiller
avec des générateurs proposé par des
entrepreneurs privés depuis la chute de
saddam hussein en 2003 aucun ministre de
l'électricité n'a été capable de
terminer son mandat
tous ont démissionné ou ont été limogés
pour satisfaire la rue une rue qui
encore gronder ce week end à bagdad
deux manifestants ont été tués après des
tirs de grenades lacrymogènes de
policiers place tahrir les premiers
morts de la contestation sous le nouveau
gouvernement irakien accusées de
reproduire les violences de son
prédécesseur le premier ministre irakien
moustapha al-qasimi ordonne une enquête
sur la mort des deux manifestants
les jeunes qui manifestaient exercer un
droit légitime et les forces de sécurité
n'avaient aucune autorisation pour tirer
ne serait ce qu'une seule balle en
direction de nos frères les manifestants
une enquête a été ouverte sur ce qu'il
s'est passé place tahrir et j'ai demandé
à voir les résultats sous 72 heures en
mai dernier lors de sa prise de pouvoir
le nouveau premier ministre était
d'ailleurs déjà engagé à faire la
lumière sur les centaines de morts au
cours des derniers mois de
manifestations des manifestations
déclenchées en octobre 2019 pour
dénoncer la corruption réclamer des
emplois et des services fonctionnels
ayant fait plus de 550 morts et des
dizaines de milliers de blessés dans
tout le pays même si le mouvement a
perdu de son ardeur quelques dizaines de
protestataires continuent d'occuper les
tentes place tahrir
[Applaudissements]